most of us know what a dragon sounds
like but they don't actually exist and
none can stop me so how does Hollywood
know how to make themselves
[Music]
just like visual artists sound designers
take inspiration from the world around
them the sounds for creatures like
dragons dinosaurs and even Chewbacca are
based on real-world animals a sound
designer may use sounds from lions
elephants cats and even tortoises to
create the sound for just one dragon the
lair sounds together to create the sound
of a non-existent creature Paul of
Fairfield is a sound designer for Game
of Thrones over the last five seasons
Paula has carefully crafted the sounds
of drogon rhaegal and Viserion
she even used the vocal screams of fans
to create the sound generated by
vissarion's icy breath in the season 7
finale
the final sound design of a scene is
complex it masks the individual sound
effects so the viewer can't identify the
sources but we can build our own
simplified version of a dragon sound
combine some alligator
a little elephants course add a pig and
you've got the sound of a dragon
but these are complex creatures dragons
do more than just roar and breathe fire
sound designers also use sound to craft
a performance for the dragon just like
Daenerys Drogo needs to act and perform
sound designers take emotional cues from
animals to influence the sounds they
create dragon is unique and sound
designers are always trying something
new in the hobbit director Peter Jackson
used Benedict Cumberbatch's original
performance as Smaug to influence the
sound design of the dragon many of the
pauses hisses and vocal affectations
came from Cumberbatch these details help
make Smaug incredibly impactful and
memorable and in the how to train your
dragon series sound designer
Randy Tom used different types of sounds
for each species of dragon giving each
type of creature their own unique sound
dragons and other fantastical creatures
add a larger-than-life element stories
the most memorable dragons leave space
for the sound to have an emotional
effect on the viewer without the
incredible sound design Game of Thrones
and How to Train Your Dragon may not be
as memorable a beautiful wasn't the word
I was thinking of what but yes
yeah